To conclude our discussion of information theory, we will
also discuss something called Kullback-Leibler divergence. It is also famously
called the KL divergence. And you must have heard this
term in our previous lectures. So it is useful to
realize that mutual information is also a particular case
of KL divergence. So KL divergence actually measures the difference
between any two distributions. It is used as a distance
measure. For this particular lesson, it is sufficient to understand
how KL divergence is used to measure the distance between
two distributions. The KL divergence is given by this particular
formula. And it is always non-negative and zero only when
P is equal to Q. When P is equal to Q,
the log of 1 is zero, and that's why the
distance is zero. Otherwise, it is always some non-negative quantity. So
it serves as a distance measure. But it is not
completely a distance measure because it doesn't follow the triangle law.
But then you should ask yourself why you need to
know KL divergence, or where it is used. Usually, and usually
in supervised learning you are always trying to model our
data to a particular distribution. So in that case our distrib,
one of our distributions can be of unknown distribution. And
we can denote that as P of X. And then can
sample our data set to find out Q of X.
While doing that, we can use KL divergence as a substitute
to the least square formula that we used for
fitting. So it's just a different way of trying to
fit your data to your existing model. And we'll come
back to KL divergence in some of our problem sets.